so it's Trump unleashed tweets that
triggered the media to meltdown an
anti-fog disciple armed with a rifle and
homemade bombs attacked an immigration
center he died the press was busy
obsessing over the Squa debts so it
garnered minimal coverage it's easy to
see why the man used the same
concentration camp rhetoric we heard
from the squad leader he identified as
part of an tyfa the group praised by CNN
so it's hard for them to condemn
something when the terrorist is merely
parroting stuff you say when you spend
your time comparing immigration agents
many of whom are minorities to Nazis and
so on
how can you trash a fan of your work
it's why they embrace Smollett
how can you expose a hoax when you've
been selling that same hoax for years
but we shouldn't do what the media likes
to do to you when a racist commits an
act of violence they will expand their
invective to include anyone tangentially
related meaning if a violent racist
likes fries and you like fries you're a
racist and probably an overweight one so
we should point out that this this dead
guy doesn't reflect all Democrats he was
just another nut
he wanted to become what the media
glorifies an avenging angel wielding
righteous violence that comes when your
enemy is not just deemed wrong but evil
the result Milkshakes mobs masks and
mayhem punch a Nazi has now punch anyone
so this guy really didn't die for a
cause he died to impress a bunch of
losers he died hoping that CNN would say
well his heart was in the right place
who knows maybe they will so Capri but I
will say I always say that this both
sides have crazies and crane should not
define your side which is why it's the
responsibility of that side to police
their own crazies i police my crazies
like Jes well there's there's plenty of
crazy there's plenty of crazies to go
around on both sides a mean and this is
exactly right for me it's all about
consistency okay right so you bring up
the fact that the media did not cover
this in a way saying well you know this
person echoed a o'seas remarks so
therefore somehow they've been you know
these these sentiments have been
manifested in this kind of violence
right which we see all the time on the
other side of a you know
someone appropriates Magda or is wearing
a Mac and again write that all of a
sudden well let's talk about the guy in
the van as well the guy who was living
in a van down by the side of the river
who was a Bernie supporter who shot up
the Congressional baseball game practice
so there's enough to go around but
here's the deal they're all crazies and
if we're going to cover it we need to do
it consistency consistently maybe this
person was influenced by aoc and it
needs to be told in the same manner as
someone who may have somehow been
motivated to you know send that bombs to
CNN like the crazy with the the crazy
guy in the band yeah they're crazy guys
yeah that was the one I was talking
about the guy in Miami with all the
stickers yes be consistent that's all I
asked yes thankfully Dana none of the
things that you writes influence crazy
people there's nobody no Jasper fanatics
remember the Pittsburgh synagogue
shooting was just so horrible and
immediately that was blamed on Trump
right but then it turned out that he was
against Trump yeah yeah that's right
and then you know and it's it is it is a
frustrating type of thing but I don't I
don't like the whole eye for an eye
thing remember the Sarah Palin
crosshairs they and they blamed that on
her too and this really did get did not
get a much attention you had somebody
trying to attack a government building
yeah that's a big deal and he died in a
confrontation with the cops Jesse yeah
the media does not report the news they
report the narrative Greg and one of the
big narrative that occurred on a coffee
mug the water go to Cafe Press and then
I think the biggest narrative out there
that the write is violent and the left
is not so even when some guy let's say
smirks at somebody that's considered a
violent act when there's an actual
violent act it's not covered two of the
three networks didn't even cover the
story and then all of the mainstream
media never reported the connection
between an Tifa and the attack not only
that they will frame as Dana said
conservatives like they did Palin
remember the Aurora Colorado shooting
ABC's Brian Watt Ross went right to it
and said it was a Tea Party supporter
they actually got his name wrong and it
wasn't that guy but on the other hand
you have eco-terrorists you have black
lives matter riders you have Bernie bro
shooters you haven't 'if you have WTO
anarchists you have all these people
running around
committing violent acts and they are
never treated in the same way they're
always excused as social justice
Crusaders or victims of capitalism
they're never treated the way the
right-wing violent people are and I was
just permission to make a social
experiment suggestion oh my god I'm
scared
put a maggot hat on and walk down the
Greenwich Village do a few laps around
the block
put a Obama hope and change t-shirt on
go down to the Florida Panhandle go to
the Florida panel see who is verbally
and physically assaulted and see who's
not I think we know what the answer I'm
gonna put it on my Mary Ann Williams
insurance just go to Palm Beach
Jesse's point except there's something
weird about how righteous violence is
romanticized in the in I would say in
the entertainment industry in the
academia cuz The Weather Underground
became Bill Ayers became a professor the
SLA was a Charles Manson was was
romanticized but they put the bomb at
Boston bomber on the front cover of
Rolling Stone so it's kind of like it's
we don't romanticize our crazies no they
do and there is the justification of
violence over and over again in this in
this crazy political day and age by the
left wing nuts in the sense and what
bothers me is it's the same thing that
rape victims have heard for decades and
decades that you brought this on
yourself they did that you asked for it
yeah and we need we need to fight back
and so we will attack you I just want to
know what is what is acceptable to the
left is it tire irons is it is it
punching somebody in the face is it
concussions is it rape is it murder
because I'll tell you with this ant if a
guy it would be a 24-hour
seven-day-a-week news cycle of sneering
snorting and just screaming to the high
heavens about how conservatives calls
this about how this is the fault of the
Fox News Channel we all know that's
exactly where violence is unacceptable
no matter who's who is does it end of
story
unless it's a cage match then you get
paid